one thing that i find really interesting
and find
to be part of the compelling case that
esports will be the future is a lot of
traditional sports team owners have
bought esports teams right
um so maybe like i would love to hear
from you a little bit about that and
just why you really see esports as being
the future
and moving into the mainstream or what
the case is for that yeah i've worked on
like dozens of those deals right so i
i've been in the room with the sports
team owner time and time again as
they're expressing why it's interesting
to them
and they're depending on who you're
talking about there are a bunch of
reasons why you know
cross promotion engage younger audiences
whatever but
across the board if there's one thing
that i think is at least in the back of
everyone's mind it's that
at some point someone paid 100 million
dollars for an mba franchise and
everyone thought that person was crazy
fast forward to today and the worst nba
franchise is worth a billion dollars
so there's a little bit of schmuck
insurance here of like the writing is on
the wall this is going to be popular and
like
i have an opportunity on the ground
floor so why don't i just like plant a
flag there and see where this
goes right and where this is going
100 that is inarguable
is full mainstream penetration so the
you know you've both made the point that
we're not there yet we're not there yet
in the us
we are there in certain places so so
korea south korea is kind of the mecca
of esports is where a lot of this was
born
and it's full cultural penetration in
south korea right i mean
you know we talked about football being
like that zach in the us you know the
the quarterback of the football team and
the small town in texas is like
guaranteed to be the most popular kid at
the school well
like the best league of legends player
is like guaranteed the most popular kid
at the korean high school right and
where are they going to hang out they're
going to hang out in pc bungs which are
basically
cafe bars where you can hang out drink
you know have fun with your friends and
play games and it's just a huge part of
korean culture
and there are places you know china is
another one where the mainstream
penetration is far ahead
there than it is here you know the most
popular league of legends player in
china is sponsored by nike already
right um so there are places where
that's already happened now it has not
happened for the most part
in the us and we are trending very much
up
right so ninja's the most famous gamer
first famous western gamer on planet
earth
he's a former halo professional player
former esports player or athlete
depending on what term you want to use
um who became very popular along with
the game fortnite and he's
you know he's been on the cover of espn
the magazine
and he was part of a new year's eve time
square thing and
he has his own line with adidas and
he is insanely famous right i mean you
know
he's a very well-known person
particularly among younger generations
now he
straddles the gaming esports line right
he's not an active esports professional
player anymore he's a former pro
turned full-time content creator um
right but
the ceiling of how famous a gamer can be
is already pretty high and it's just
gonna keep going up right i talked about
as being in the bottom half of the
second and eating this thing
you know picking arbitrage what everyone
40 years old or younger
grew up in a world where video games
even existed basically right so that
means like
well over half the world population grew
up without them and we convert these
people all the time you know there are
people older than 40 who didn't grow up
with games who start playing games later
or become esports fans
but it's hard but the thing is in the
long run i don't need to convert them
right
i frequently make a joke that pisses
people off which is every day
a baseball fan dies and two esports fans
are born right
um median media age of a baseball fans
in the 50s right
the overwhelming majority of my audience
is under 35. so
every day more esports fans are born and
that's why i'm 100 convinced that in 30
years when we're listing the biggest
sports in the world
we're going to say soccer i'm going to
say a video game because we're already
on this trajectory the writing is on the
wall i was on the wall then i said the
exact same thing
in a partner meeting at the third
largest law firm in seattle when i
started my career i started building a
practice that all the
you know old white dudes at my firm were
like what the hell is going on
and i said this is what's going on like
this is the data it's going to happen
it's inevitable and it was
there were also there were people there
who supported me but a lot of people who
didn't
right i went out and kind of forged my
my own entrepreneurial path for a reason
you know i said it in a talk in 2016 and
i'll keep saying it like this is where
this is all going it's going up and to
the right
in 30 years the most famous esports
players in the us
will be you know famous in the same way
that an nba player is famous this is
just inevitable the thesis that people
want to watch other people play video
games
open shut down i'm curious i think video
games
andrew this wrote about this in his book
is um something a lot of
men are attracted to um
but i also have this vision of
one of the first sports where men and
women can compete
against each other on without without
the limitations of a physical
um physical traits and like on
relatively equal ground i guess
the definition of equal ground is that
are you guys seeing
gender diversity and more women joining
the sport or i'm curious demographics
and who's playing
so by and large we're not and it's a
huge problem but to to start with the
premise
you know it's not correct to say that
that gamers are mostly
or are like you know predominantly men
right of the three billion gamers in the
world somewhere between 40 and 45
of them are women depending on what
market research that you're looking at
now
that is all gaming right there are
certain sections of the population
that are deeply interested in certain
types of gaming like if you want to know
the player base of candy crush it is
overwhelmingly women right and there are
millions of people that play candy crush
right so
uh the esports titles the league of
legends and counter-strike of the world
still
are predominantly men uh and there are
the layers of this problem we could do
an hour on gender discrimination in
gaming and it's something i try to
actively work on every
every chance i get and so here's what it
looks like right like why are there
fewer
female engineers than there are male
engineers right
it starts from a very young age when
parents tell their
you know daughters and sons what they
are and are not supposed to do you know
son don't play with this doll
go play this sport you know
girl stop playing this video game start
doing this other thing
instead right it's unbelievable how much
these cultural norms affect us and
affect what we're interested in from a
very young age and these things play
out over the course of the entire over
your entire life you know a girl
that was is super into video games in
high school is going to be treated
differently
right there there are cultural norms
that tell her she's a nerd she's an
outcast right she's an outlier she's not
doing what she's supposed to be doing
and it's a real problem and then you get
into the games themselves and
the harassment is unbelievable i mean
any any game
where there are voice communications if
you if you have friends who are women
who play games ask them what their
experience is like
and they will have one of two answers i
don't use voice communications in
in the game because i'm just i just
can't i don't want to be harassed i'm
over it
or two i do it and i'm constantly have
my teammates
harassing me saying horrible things to
me intentionally losing games because
the game because they're on the same
team as a girl it's uh it's it is
horrible um and so and then they face
harassment you know you you do get
through all of this stuff to be
a professional female gamer
in some capacity in a game or a content
creator whatever
and you are harassed constantly on your
social media handles on your twitch
stream
you know the the the parties in power
are not doing enough job to correct this
but if we're being
honest about it this is a problem that
goes so deep there are so many layers to
why these things happen
and it's you know there are there are a
lot of very good things that are
happening you know
girls who code write in projects like
this who are trying to push the bounds
of getting more gender diversity in
professions where there is no reason why
they are dominated by men but there were
no one reason why but there are you know
all these layers of problem and it very
much
exists in my industry as well i hate it
i try to do what i can about it but yeah
you're zach the premise is correct there
is no reason why
a man should be better at league of
legends than a woman or a man to be
better at counter-strike than a woman
but when you look at the professional
player base of these games
they are almost exclusively men some of
them are 100
men there are no women playing in the
north american league of legends
championship series and
in north you know and and that's a
problem new and innovative technologies
the cutting edge sadly a lot of times
when that
is hap when they in the nascent stages
when they're being built and the process
is being built and that's how they when
it's
predominantly men the the
the issues you're highlighting aren't
addressed early on and so then you have
this entire system to fight against to
even rewire it once it gets a little
more popular
i was a computer science minor in
college and i you know
i was sort of aware of of this problem
then because i had professors who were
into gaming or into
gaming platforms and would talk about
the harassment and i know in conferences
it's always been really bad at gaming
conferences and doxxing
is is a phenomenon that's very prominent
in the gaming community and especially
towards women so this was you know
probably seven years ago or whatever
that
this this was sort of at the forefront
of things i was thinking about and knew
about
but i haven't kept up with it like how
are you seeing improvements at least
as much as it still has a long way to go
at the margins we are seeing improvement
i mean i don't want to say that we've
seen no improvement because we have
there's some thoughtfulness around this
i mean
you know riot games for example it's not
just the professional player base it's
throughout the gaming industry right if
you want to work in gaming and you're a
woman
the amount of adversity that you are
facing is significantly higher than for
your male peers anyone who denies that
as an idiot
um and there were you know for example
there were
active lawsuits against riot games and
there was a ton discussed about the
culture of riot games
and there were some things about acute
discrimination but there were also
things where like
they had a bar as part of their
admission process where it's like you
have to be a hardcore gamer otherwise
we're not really interested in hiring
you
and if you do that if you set a hardcore
gamer bar which on its face seems like a
neutral criteria we are a hardcore
gaming company
we want hardcore gamers working here you
are neglecting the reality that
a man is far more likely to be a
hardcore gamer because of all of the
other things i talked about leading up
to the moment in time
where this person applied to work at
riot games and so
um you know riot culture has changed
meaningfully it's not perfect
there's there was a lawsuit filed
recently against the ceo for gender
discrimination so which is you know it's
an allegation i'm not saying it's true
or false right i have no idea but
it's not we're far from perfect on that
stuff but there have been
some improvements i'm always hesitant to
give us too much of a pat on the back
for this because
the the problem is still so bad and i
literally cannot have a conversation
with my female friends who work in the
industry without hearing more and more
stories about
what it is like to just be them and and
the the challenges that they face on a
daily basis the discrimination in a
business meeting you know
i'm i'm on the board of an amazing
company that is has two female founders
and
if i attend a meeting with them they are
the founders
they is their company i am just there
right
and we're across from a man in a meeting
one out of two times they'll have a
conversation with me like i'm like
you're asking about their company
talk to them right like why is this a
con i'm here to support i can add some
context value whatever but like this is
a conversation between you
and these two amazing women and i'm
along for this ride and it's just
it is you know as much as we've come
a long way over the course of the last
five years carly we still have
so much more to go that's really
frustrating and
makes some sense
[Music]
you